انهيار نظام الصحي خطر يهدد السودان الان
بسبب المواجهات المسلحه تقول منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان 61% من المرافق الصحيه في
الخرطوم اغلقت وان 16% فقط منها تعمل بشكل
طبيعي
منذ اليوم الاول اندلاع المواجهات ركزت في
وسط المدينه حيث توجد اغلب المرافق الصحيه
تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان ثلاثه
ارباع المستشفيات في مناطق الاشتباكات
بالعاصمه السودانيه توقفت عن العمل يجد
العاملون في المؤسسات الطبيه انفسهم امام
معركتين الان استقبال واسعاف المصابين
ومواجهتها هجمات مسلحه حسب نقابه الاطباء
قصف مسلحون ثلاثه عشر مستشفى في مختلف
انحاء البلاد وتم افراغ 19 مستشفى اخر اما
منظمه الصحه العالميه فاحصى ثمانيه قتله
على الاقل فيها هجمات مباشره على مستشفيات
يعاني السودانيون للحصول على ادويه خصوصا
للامراض المزمنه وتحذر منظمه يونيسيف من
انما قيمته 40 مليون دولار من اللقاحات
ومن ماده الانسولين مهدده بالتلف في
مخازنها بسبب انقطاعات التيار الكهرب
وتوقف امدادات البنزين كل هذه التطورات
دفعت منظمه الصحه العالميه الى توقع مزيد
من الوفيات جراء نقص الخدمات ليتحول هذا
النقص ايضا الى سلاح فتاك يفرض هذا الوضع
تحديات جديده على النظام صحي هش ساهمت
عوامل عده في تفككه منها الاضطرابات
السياسيه والعسكريه وضعف الموارد وهجره
الادمغه حسب ارقام منظمه الصحه العالميه
فان اكثر من عشره ملايين سوداني في حاجه
لمساعدات طبيه
وتشير الاحصائيات الى ان السودان خسر نحو
60% من اطباءه بسبب الهجره التي تسببت
فيها الاضطرابات السياسيه وما رافقها من
ازمات اقتصاديه امام هذا الوضع يبدو
احتمال استمرار المواجهات العسكريه
كالكابوس بالنسبه الى السودانيين لان
نظامهم الصحي المنهك لن يتحمل تبعات حرب
مفتوحه على المجهول